it's great to be joined today by
Gabriella gen Cola who's the CEO and
co-founder of key B this is a very
interesting project Gabriella and it's
related to something that I sort of
personally am interested in because I'm
aware that all of the different places
that I have a loyalty card or some
number of points whether it's like eBags
calm or I once bought a laptop sleeve or
the local ice cream shop I have this
huge amount of accumulating loyalty
points that I number-one don't even
remember having number two it's unclear
what what the value is and number three
as the as a business owner I also
recognize that having all of these
loyalty points sort of out there is a
financial liability in a sense it's
deferred revenue and it impacts my
balance sheet and sort of my financial
standing so talk a little bit about the
problem in the loyalty points world in
general
sure so you actually you actually pretty
much summarized it pretty good because
it's it's all about the customer has the
maybe main pane of the customer is
really you have so many loyalty programs
and you earn from them all those points
you get promised a lot of nice stuff but
at the end of the day there are not so
many think about airline miles for
example most people just fly a few times
a year so every time several years
actually to really get to a nice a nice
reward so the ideas we need to say okay
we have all those customers in those
loyalty programs that actually can't
really move those points due to any
other places that they can see any value
behind those points so the main idea is
really is really to to help the
customers to solve that pain and on the
other side the pain of the brand we
choose that since the customers have a
really low engagement and they don't
spend the points they stay on the
balance sheet of the of the brand as a
liability now
the more liability that creates the the
worst situation for the for the company
and the idea is really to say okay with
the point you're giving out a promise as
a company that's why you actually why
you actually have to put it as a
liability now on the other side with
with our system or giving out let's say
a branded token which is backed by the
key B token the idea is that every brand
the token has a real value behind it so
you as a company you actually don't have
to put it as a liability on your balance
sheet when you give out a brand token
and the customer actually receives a
real value because every brand the token
has a ratio to the PB token yeah so
let's see like that through if we if we
can talk that through in parts right so
let's first think about it from the
point of view of the brand I am you know
David's frozen yogurt shop and I give
out one free yogurt for every ten paid
yogurts and of course this is like a
brick and mortar business and I
understand that's not necessarily like
the best use case but just for our
hypothetical so there's sort of an
implicit value right each point I guess
is worth one tenth of a yogurt because
for every ten yogurts you get a free
yogurt or something like that if I want
to use the key B platform and put my
program within your system how does that
work the it works like that you you will
calculate okay how many of those that
the content you explained it's a bit
like a punch card every time you get a
yogurt the eleventh one is a moment you
would have to calculate as a brand okay
how many punch cards or how many punches
are you giving out actually in a month
in a quarter in a year and that value
you bite with that value you buy key B
tokens okay
so you keep it tokens you key be tokens
in that moment I'm have have a market
value of X dollars now as soon as you
create your own branded Oken let's say
that yogurt coin and I never
you said the ratio between the yogurt
coin and the the cubital so for example
in your example it will be one key B
token is maybe one that one one your
good phone or you maybe can say you know
what I want to do it a bit gaming fight
and maybe you put a number of yoga coins
higher so you have her yogurt coin less
US dollar value or less key betoken
value but you have you're giving out
more coins that could be more attractive
in certain cases where the amount is
really low so psychologically a bigger
amount of coins makes much more fun and
so that is the connection between having
really a value behind those tokens and
the idea is then that you as a user for
example you like really you love yogurt
so you have a lab jeweler I love I love
ice cream so I have a lot of I don't
have a lot of ice cream cards but it can
be done maybe once I would like to get a
yogurt and you maybe would like sorry to
get an ice cream in that moment
it makes sense if we two can exchange
those those coins and you get your ice
cream and I get my yogurt so since
there's kind of like a centralized value
that links all of these loyalty programs
we're in the real world you might say
well an American Airlines frequent flyer
miles worth maybe a penny right for the
sake of it and then a Starwood's rewards
point might be worth 1.5 cents so there
is sort of a relative value but these
aren't programs that are necessarily
connected through any central system of
accounting the key be platform will
actually make those various loyalty
points or miles or whatever interrelated
right so the idea is really to to give
the brands the the brands and the users
of possibility to really make those
points those tokenize points in that
moment
exchangeable and the idea is if you try
to use a centralized database to do that
all the brands need to trust you as as
the authority over that central database
that you really have the security that
you can manage the security it won't be
hacked you don't manipulate all the all
the numbers so
there is where blockchain really comes
into play because um if you have if you
have a trustless trustless that's a
foundation for all this loyalty program
you don't have AI that the points aren't
going to be manipulated and that it was
that let's say that is but the missing
part which was missing in there in the
last year's and why also the the loyalty
market couldn't be really connected can
you talk a little bit about I'm very
interested in in the financial impact on
the business right so we know like for
example the big us-based
Airlines like American Airlines because
of the number of miles that are out
there which could at any time be
redeemed for flights there are millions
and millions and millions of dollars
that are effectively liabilities for
American Airlines that at anytime they
could be called in and people could
start redeeming those miles for flights
and that is a direct impact on American
Airlines availability for seating etc
how does moving to the key B platform
change the financial relationship of the
business to those outstanding to what's
effectively a liability yeah so the idea
is following you can imagine it like
that from that moment were you as a
brand will use our technology and you
give out a branded token instead of a
point from that moment on you on you
won't build any more liabilities so the
liabilities you already have they won't
grow so that's already a benefit because
until now they were growing like like
really fast and on the other side if you
want to delete all the liabilities you
have in that moment of course and that
is the and that is the whole logic
behind those liabilities the the amount
that you set their newest dollar is the
amount behind those are meeting points
so you would have to start to go to
active users and so replacing their
points with branded tokens
I think I understand and it seems like
it's important also that because the
tokens are based on the underlying Kibby
token that it has a market value so even
if I say for example an American
Airlines mile is worth a penny I can't
actually sell the American Airlines mile
for a penny it doesn't actually have
market value we can assess sort of what
it would be worth exchange for flights
is part of the idea that because the
token itself has a market value that
it's no longer a liability for the
business or am i misunderstanding that
it's perfectly right it's perfect
lighting and the value derives actually
from the demands that the brands have to
buy the token to back up their own
branded token so that's the cool thing
it's it's super connected on one side
you have you have the the base curve and
on the other side the brands that really
push the whole demands the loyalty
programs providers that push the demand
I think that that is the there is the
nice part at the whole let's say circle
of the token can you talk a little bit
about the process of the ico
where you are where you're looking to do
and what the timeline is so what we did
is we splitted up the token sailing in
two parts and the idea was really to in
the first part to get the smaller
smaller amount of funds that was around
three Millions and the idea was to to
really get the first ones to expand the
team create the product and of course
acquire the first brands and that's
really what we did we expanded the team
from 7 to 15 people from 2 to 5 deaths
for example we really had a lot of heard
of growth in the whole team we've build
a specific marketing team in tel-aviv
and the idea was really to create the
product at least one part of the product
and acquire the first brand that's
really that's really keen to use that
technology because right now what we see
in the whole space is you have a lot of
project
having really cool ideas but there is
not that much execution behind it and so
we wanted to do is really bring a lot
more execution behind our idea and you
had a cool thing is really we have
closed the first brand now the testo
which is the second largest cold coffee
producer in Switzerland they have their
first rollout now in seven countries
here in Europe and we've closed the
second German brand we are in talks with
another three or were actually um before
closing them another three brands so we
really see a really strong demand from
the brand side because they have loyalty
and of course also blockchain as a
really high priority loyalty because
they all need loyal customers to really
survive and on the other side they are
all looking really keen on blockchain
and what they actually can do with it
and the cool thing is that they they
really they really tell us that it is
super easy to explain there for a CEO
for example to the owner of a company or
to the to the executive board it is much
easier to explain block chaining in the
connection with a loyalty system because
that is something that people know and
that people already can can but say it
is more tangible for them and so we see
is really strong demand from that side
and we wanted to use that for to create
really traction before them we do a
bigger part of the token sale right now
were for private sale mode were having a
really really good already close the
first ones where we don't only get funds
but we really get partners on board that
will distribute the technology that will
open doors add more brands and what
first were on boarding a lot of brands
and and selling a lot of tokens also to
those brands so what we're really
looking is that we have as much as a
clean token sale as possible and really
really focus on what is needed for the
ecosystem and for the long-term success
of
[ __ ] as a technology and not just to
focus on the talking saying itself raise
some money and then see okay what are we
going to do with that with the money
well if you succeed my wallet will
shrink by about 95% because I'll be able
to get rid of you know if I'm ever back
in New Jersey at a particular bagel shop
now I won't need to carry around this
punch card so I think that that would be
a really really good thing
Gabriela Jen Jen : CEO and co-founder of
key B you can use the links in the video
description to find out more I really
appreciate you telling us about the
project thank you very much it was
really nice talking to you David and
thank you very much for invitation was
really awesome